hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from round 11 of the Tata
steel Challengers we already know what
happened in the Masters we reign supreme
over there but here Leon luk menona won
the Challenger section and next year he
will be joining the Masters in the
masters section as uh he qualified via
the challengers uh and I well I I was
trying to figure out which game to show
you which game you guys would enjoy most
and I'm pretty sure this is the one it's
from around 11 and 11 uh Luke had a
great second half of the tournament he
started in the first half of the
tournament by losing two games he lost
Liam Frolic and irin lamei but in the
second half of the tournament out of the
last seven games he got six and a half
points drawing only uh his game to Hans
nean now let's check out this game we
already featured U Mustafa once on this
channel I think it was also a loss by
him so uh third time we feature him it
will be a win no worries there uh so
let's check it out and um why this game
is so nice so Le luk has the white
pieces and he opens with Pawn to E4 we
have Pawn to E5 Knight F3 Knight to C6
and Bishop to C4 uh the Italian game is
on the board we have Bishop to C5 the
Joo piano and now D3 the Joo panimo we
have Knight to F6 and Bishop to G5
continuing in the spirit of Joo panimo
we have D6 C3 and pawn to H6 uh nothing
new here all been played before Bishop
to H4 and pawn to A6 and now Pawn to A4
Knight B to D2 are the standard moves
here castles has been played before but
it is a bit um more rare than the other
two lines uh Bishop back to A7 and now
Knight B to D2 We have Pawn to G5 Bishop
to G3 and now Knight to H7 and um you're
probably thinking okay White Castle King
said very early on black still hasn't
Castle so black will probably play
Knight to f8 Knight to G6 uh and then
just start advancing those pawns and
attack the white king and that would be
a fairly good assumption but after King
to H1 uh there is a game where Knight to
f8 was played hi Mart roen played it
against adiban in the grand swis of 2021
and he won that game but here we have
just castles and it does look look to be
a bit of a bit of an odd move uh as why
not just attack the white king but okay
uh he wanted to play a different game
and it is now as of move 11 that we have
a completely new game so Pawn to A4
white wants to start a minority attack
on the queen side and now King to h8
unpinning from the this diagonal and he
wants to strike with Pawn to F5 Pawn to
B4 and now Pawn to
H5 uh trying to trap the bishop in Pawn
to H3 Pawn to H4 and Bishop to H2 and
now even Pawn to G4 so he is going after
the white king only with his King tucked
away all the way on h8 we have H
captures on G4 Bishop captures now
pinning the Knight and here here uh we
have this queen to E1 move now Queen to
E1 uh perhaps a slight imprecision I
will just show you uh objectively how
how the the position should be played as
uh well the
then equilibrium is kept Pawn to B5 it
does seem to be the way to go and after
Knight A5 D4 and after Knight captures
on C4 Knight captures on C4 now you go
Knight to G5 put pressure on the F3
Knight and now Queen to D3 you and pin
and after H3 Knight captures on G5 Queen
captures uh or maybe even better H
captures on G2 first and after King
captures Queen captures on G5 Queen to
E3 offering a queen trade not allowing
any nasty discoveries Rook to G8 and now
Bishop to G3 uh not allowing the The
Rook to harass the white king here and
here we probably see everything get
traded off with uh uh maybe even Knight
captures any E3 better putting pressure
on the bishop and after Bishop goes back
you can't really capture on D4 even
though you're attacking it twice because
then there's Rook to H1 check and after
the king moves you pick up the free
Bishop so you have to react to that
first and now uh probably you know the
the game just continues B captures B
captures Rook a to D1 and it's a fine
position for both black does have the
bishop pair but the white king is maybe
a little bit safer although probably not
relevant so that's uh the objective way
to do it as our you know artificial
artificial overlords are telling us but
after Queen to E1 now black should go
Queen to F6 double Rooks on the G file
and start an attack against the white
king but Mustafa starts with Pawn to F5
first and it is sort of in the spirit of
the Poss because he already played King
h8 he wants to play F5 uh but now pon to
B5 is just very strong and unless you
play Knight to E7 is just straight up
winning so in the game Knight the A5 was
played and now feel free to pause the
video and win the game for Leon Luke
mandona while I give you a couple of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on uh
finding this uh beautiful sacrifice and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is night captures on E5
that's the stuff and uh there's no good
move here yeah you probably shouldn't
capture but not capturing and the Knight
to G6 check uh also if even if you throw
in a knight captures on C4 first still
Knights to G6 check and I have King F
King G7 Knight captures and after King
captures there's also Knight captures
and C4 and now the black king will just
get um massacred here so after Knight
captures on E5 D captures on E5 was
played allowing this bishop to deliver
check so Bishop captures an E5 and now
Knight to F6 blocking check we have Pawn
to F3 attacking the bishop and now
Knight captures on C4 but now uh not
Queen captures on H4 you think okay it's
a very nice in between move but the
problem is if Queen captures King G7 and
now Rook to h8 is a problem you don't
have time to play Knight captures on C4
which means you're going to be down
material at the end of this line so
instead after Knight captures on C4
Knight captures on C4 there's always
time to capture the pawn here Bishop to
H5 also the bishop is hanging so Bishop
to H5 and now Queen captures on H4 with
the threat of Queen captures on H5 as
the Knight on F6 is pinned so King G7
and now Pawn to D4 just improving the
position a little bit in the center uh
Bishop to G6 and now Queen G5 side side
stepping Rook to h8 so Rook to h8 check
King to G1 and now Rook to H5 going
after the White Queen Queen to F4 and
now Queen to D7 uh and now well you
could pretty much do anything here Pawn
to G4 is is definitely the way to go uh
but he didn't want to risk it you know
opening up his King a little bit too
much so he played Knight to E3 the idea
is of course bring the Knight to D5 put
more pressure on that F7 knight uh F6
Knight and there's no way to defend this
Pawn to C5 was played uh any other move
is insufficient um as well Knight to D5
Rook to f8 adding a Defender and now
even Pawn to B6 make the position as as
nice as possible before you capture on
F6 Bishop to B8 was played and now
Knight captures on F6 he was in this
position un move 31 that Mustafa Yas
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here I now realize I
accidentally left the Way's rating uh
let me just fix that you guys are
probably worried out wow this is one
this is one strong dude no that's not
even Way's rating that's I believe ala's
rating or maybe even ding's no that's
ding's
rating uh there we
go all right all right that's fixed and
yeah here you
resign uh what what could you try you
could try Rook captures on F6 but that
just uh you know ends in everything
getting traded off Bishop captures King
captures Queen captures and B8 and okay
you still do have to get your Rooks into
the game but it's not really dangerous
like C captures on D4 you go for a queen
trade and if Rook to H7 You'll Play E5
with check and if King E6 Queen to C4
with check and if Queen to D5 blocking
uh just Queen captures and now it's
perfectly fine Rook F to D1 you will
pick up the D4 pawn and that's it if
Rook H4 G3 uh The Rook has to move
wherever The Rook goes doesn't really
matter you could capture with the pawn
or with the Rook everything is still
winning you're up uh up the exchange
you're up um two Pawns of course
completely winning and the other way if
you go for Bishop captures on E5 first
trying to be tricky then not Knight
captures on D7 instead Knight captures
on H5 with check and after Bishop
captures Queen captures on E5 also with
check and after the king moves you can
even pick up more material doesn't
doesn't really matter uh you're up the
exchange you have a massive Center here
your your king is much safer than the
black king of course completely winning
for white uh so yeah after this uh 31st
move Knight captures on F6 most of Elman
resigned and very very nice victory for
Leon luk menona like I said out of the
last seven games in the second half of
the tournament he got six and a half
points only drawing to Hans M Neiman so
incredible stuff uh even these are let
me just show you these are the standings
uh of the of the Challenger section so
uh Leon luk menona first with n and a
half points in second place Daniel darta
and Mark Andrea Mai Mark Andrea Mai is
the world junior champion last year he
won the world junior Championship and he
was uh having an incredible tournament
he was in the lead but later on Leon uh
Luke Leon overtook him then with eight
and a half we have Anton corov and Irvin
lamei Anon corbo's game against l lukan
donka is
really uh is really something else if
you guys want we can even check out that
one because korobov was winning pretty
much the entire game and then he just
lost it was really really something else
uh with seven and a half points Alis
salm with seven points Hans miman and
jimy Santos latasa with five and a half
Liam Frolic and Hari kadron naali with
five Mustafa ilmas with four and a half
Diva deshmuk and with two and a half
Stefan B and Elena robers Elena rubar
with two points she did get those two
brilliant victories but it just wasn't
her tournament uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it if you
have any other games that you would like
to see from The Challengers do use
hashtag suggestion and I will very
gladly go over them and yeah I would
like to thank ala Simo please uh Samuel
Kane ghard hlan Jeremy an anitos and
David gasparian for your contribution to
my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World uh so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day and very much looking
forward to seeing Leon look next year in
the master section of the Tata steel uh
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day